today's podcast is brought to you by
nutrafull you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutrafull.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash trash and all three of us
ladies love neutral do you want to stay
more hydrated but need a little more
oomph than water check out liquid iv
liquid iv hydrates you two times faster
and more efficiently than water alone
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com
and use the code trash tuesday that's 25
off anything you order when you shop
using promo code trash tuesday at
liquidive.com hey sluggies we have a
really insane roller coaster of an
episode we have a
surprise hidden guest that let's just
say the guest surprised us all right we
don't know where he is right now
no club he's wandering the streets
so
tune in for the drama um i have been
having such a fun time on the road i
love meeting all of you guys it's like
insane so much crazy things so many
crazy things happening during the shows
it's incredible you can see me august
12th through 13th in springfield
missouri at the blue room comedy club
it's going to be amazing i love that
club you can then see me in september
i'll be in pittsburgh tempe arizona
la jolla comedy store i'll be at the
caluso casino in california you guys
that is going to be so fun party without
a casino please god that is so fun then
uh later dates i'll be in kansas city
irvine san jose
michigan
and florida and you can go to
andyletterman.com shows to get it also
please tune in to my spotify live show
every monday at
5 p.m pst 8 p.m eastern it's so fun it's
an interactive audio show
where it's called don't bore me with
annie letterman it's your chance to
entertain me it's been so fun
and i can't wait to talk to you on there
hi you guys i am coming back on the road
and you can get tickets at esther on
ice.com i'm coming to austin phoenix
seattle and portland i'm very excited
for these shows they're going to be
really special and see you guys there
what's on your leg
tattoo
oh yeah carlos got it
no these are different and i'm like i'm
having a crisis over spending a lot of
money on sunglasses but just don't do it
next time okay okay you just take time
off oh okay i don't really spend yeah i
don't always spend a lot of money you
know you guys are going through a
different thing right now because you're
spending spending spending and we've
always been rich no i'm saying esther
is
making the spending go down right now
i'm well dave got a hold of what my
credit card bills are
how i told them
and
his reaction was really like things are
different dave's not like us he's really
not it's a different thing than us okay
i love your hair color right now
it's like
it's fully barbie well i got i'm doing a
dolly thing but barbie i'll take oh i
love that wait i want to go blond
yeah i mean i wanted to last year it'll
be it'll we can use the mustache wax no
or the mustache bleach i went oh my god
can we bleach the tops of your hairs
with mustache bleach what's that what is
that they have you never used jolie or
jolene or whatever no
it was this mustache bleach my mom and i
this was our bonding when i was a kid
we used to bleach our mustaches it was a
nightmare when the sun hits it you look
like [ __ ] you got the ticket into
willy wonka they were afraid to um
the woman gave me a consultation before
dyeing my hair last year
and
she's like your hair's already dead
there's no diet wait you got a
consultation yeah on fairfax i was like
we went to a separate room i was nervous
to take off my hat and she was like look
we can obviously do this those were the
days when he used to be nervous to take
off his hat
i miss those things
have a little shame
everyone wants me to shave it back no
don't do it i can't i want to go no no
shave no shave the sides but keep the
pubes tall don't associate it with that
the people who say that have no idea
what the three of us looked like five
years ago wait do you have the picture
of us at the
7-eleven it's
no i'm thinking of even
no we're all ugly no
honestly we're hideous monsters we're
hideous monsters it's true
i will say to you
i found i was looking at like i wanted
to look at puppy randy so i was looking
at old me inspirations
you could have just went to your
possibly the ugliest person i've ever
seen
and it was not that long ago
you looked like an ugly boy
and it was so recent that it's crazy or
you've blossomed into a beauty being
like all of us were ugly
too but i was focused in on you
i was looking at my dog so when i looked
at my side it was looking at a puppy so
i didn't even see my own face and i
looked at your side i was also looking
at a dog i will admit you on me
inspiration you looked good back in the
day but you used to get mad at me like
why are you putting like i'm like this
is going to stay on the internet forever
wait oh i was ugly
like i was definitely like a little
pudgy whatever when did it change
i don't like yeah what age what age did
you get anorexic did you get teased for
being fat or something like what
happened to you i ate a croissant and i
was gonna bring it in so you could slap
it on my hand and i couldn't finish i
kept eating it i finished it
okay thanks for telling us because that
that would have been keeping a secret if
you ate i don't know food secrets i
don't have food secrets neither i'm not
a food hider just croissant i used to be
it's really scary my mom my dad said she
found beers under my mom's bed once she
was like a beer bear fighter that's so
funny
just randomly my mom just got a little
thing just king of the house dude i like
i stopped my my secret eating was
obviously born out of like my chaotic
household where like eating is shamed
growing up but i did notice not enough
in my household not enough yeah chubby
people one time i knew i remember in me
and dave's first apartment like going
into a different room to eat cookies and
i was like this is is that what you do
to buy
clothes now
[Laughter]
she's a sunglass hider wait but carlos
you were never someone that i was like
carlos has a weight issue like you were
always normal i never thought of your
weight it was very like
i'm not thin i'm not fat i'm just like
pre dad bod i think but because i'm five
seven i almost said five eight
oh we caught a lie that's a good
i don't know i don't see how i got dates
like after i got divorced i went on a
lot of dates
[Laughter]
he would carl i could bring up like some
of the hottest girls in our business and
he'd be like she tried to bang me i
wasn't under i'm like where i
really we i feel like i remember also
could we just feel like annie's one of
them
this is the oops no kalila episode this
is like our throwback to when the three
of us used to do podcasts together and
no one watched and they were always bad
but they no
you're so full of [ __ ] they weren't bad
they were good they were no they were
how dare you how dare you i'm gonna
strike you i don't know how i got like
on raya i got i went on on dates all the
time and i'm just like how did this
happen
that's weird i actually am on andy yeah
i agree with both of you how did how did
you get on raya what was your like benji
benji
sent me an invite
and then i
yeah when i first met todd when i first
met todd he was complaining about how he
couldn't get uriah then i had to drop
him off at his shitty car i was like if
i went on a date with a guy from raya
and i showed him and this was his
[ __ ] car it was a station wagon ford
focus tan colored
it had something happened to the seat so
there was like a t-shirt over it when he
bought it so he never took the t-shirt
off because he was afraid to see what
was under the seat tied to rat village
it was so disgusting i was like i would
have burned right i would have found
ryan no lawsuit i would have burned it
to the ground what what did he say guys
raya is uh stands for rich rich [ __ ]
young [ __ ] ew
that's not my friend karen that's pretty
good can margolis that's her joke
never are you scared to talk [ __ ] on
because you might be there one day no no
i just i haven't you're
you can do the just friends section
esther now just friends is so annoying
what are you talking about everything i
hear about raya is so horrible that i
have no interest like i think i would
sooner go on tinder or bumble than riot
because raya is like it seems like it's
rich [ __ ] loser guys
and then like 12 year old girls that
they want to have sex with carl so you
would crash
you're a crash that needs to see a 12
year old wait actually
you can go lesbian on there too
really yeah is my lipstick all [ __ ] up
is there anything no no okay
wait do you know what is so cringe that
the three of us did did a podcast
talking about other podcasts we did
we
went on a walk
and then we were all really hungry but
only had 20 this was in the pandemic oh
my gosh
one of us only had one 20 dollar bill
and we like
annie the rich guys i always was
destined to be rich
and we had to like go sit down at a
restaurant and be like so we only have
20 this was like a year ago yeah this
was so recent
we're like we only have 20 we're so
sorry to be the we're in our 30s
we promise some of us don't look bad and
we look kidnapped we all split we
haven't sold into sex trafficking yet so
we only have 20 dollars but it's like it
really was like a junior high moment
where like you only have a certain
amount you got thai food too you
definitely let me i was the alpha in
that group and you guys didn't really
want to let me know that but we went to
seven of like
thai food yeah it was so rare you
wouldn't have allowed thai food
you wouldn't have wanted thai food i
like thai food i think i wasn't as
hungry as you guys and carlos i've
noticed about him is he'll kind of eat
anything if he's sharing it and it's a
small yeah
i'm big into sharing and that's carlos
is like the only person on planet earth
who i i will willingly share with
because he takes so little that it's
like
it's like fake
last year would complain about that a
little bit your ex from last year in the
summer i dated a girl oh i remember that
girl yeah yeah i was like didn't hear
about her made up but i do remember
she's not no i completely remember i
remember she's real
saying it like your page she said she
saw me at the comedy store and didn't
say anything and i was like you could
have
whatever but then she told you she saw
you that's weird
i understand if she never wants to talk
to you again she's scared of you for
some reason she's not scared of me it
was like a fine breakup i was just
saying she used to like why did she say
hi if it was such a good breakup
i don't know maybe she was just like
awkward about it i would be awkward
around an x i guess sometimes i there's
no one more awkward around an x than me
one time i was at the pot i was at
potbellies the sandwich shop at orchard
mall we know what it is and this guy
that i dated in high school walked in
and i literally did he think you were
the pig
i saw him and i went like this
[Laughter]
drawing so much attention to yourself no
it was way the worst thing did this
break you collapsed like permit it was
the worst thing you could do is i
dropped to the ground to hide and then i
do want you to feel what it feels like
to be like a fat so that breaks a chair
you'll never have that and i want you to
have that can we rig her chair at some
point so she feels so good i want you to
kill every human emotion everything
that is like i will become a lawyer too
soon to handle the case myself
i could imagine you in class making
carlos your homework
she would not pass
i was a bad student
i know you're barely passing at this
point
tell me about your tattoo it looks like
chicken cutlet material honestly well
you gotta it's like protected right now
texas or something it's such a hot girl
like drawing you got into your leg yeah
texas upside down texas because texas is
upside down or like texas is being crazy
no some people thought that and i was
like no i like it now who are these some
people bobby or
no like or santino like who else do you
guys random bad friends and trash
tuesday fans that will reply to the
instagram story i put up with a [ __ ]
tattoo
why are you cursing it
see there's what people understand
carlos has a temper yeah they think
we're mean to him i know every second of
us he's like he yeah but he's just a lot
of trouble in our lives i've not caused
true you're allowed to fight back but
you do have a little bit of a remember
when he coughed on that other friend
oh yeah i thought it was like it was
like i couldn't esther tell the story
okay
because the statue of limitations are
enough for five more years but we can
say it so it was the heart of kovacs
like like mon a month in me not even
like just really bad cop at times like
you're not even barely going the grocery
store whatever i mean this is when we
all thought like if you walked outside
you would immediately fall to your death
yeah truly and you saw your ex-boyfriend
and
so and it was like when you know when
people's birthdays were happening and it
was sad you didn't know what to do so it
was one of our friends birthdays
it was sandy's birthday and so we all
decided it was my birthday
it was your birthday yeah that's why you
guys came i know how annoying to get mad
at someone on their birthday for
coughing go over into their faces okay
so it was carlos's birthday and three of
us decided to like separately drive and
like just get be in our cars and be like
happy birthday carlos
which is so it lame by the way i'm like
did you even enjoy that i didn't drive
my birthday like a covered birthday for
carlos well i was annoyed because there
was so much honking in the alley
and i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
oh yeah it was a surprise i went on
twitter and like typed in like melrose
la brea alley like i wanted to get the
details on this new crime happening and
i go outside and it's you i forgot it
was like a prank birthday okay
so then did we egg his house we should
have thrown eggs in it you should throw
and exit him when he came out hit him in
the head so then carlos comes out and
he's like
but he's like kind of happy but just
carlos was relapsing on weed at that
point for the beginning it was the
beginning that's when i relapsed on
drinking
oh it was so annoying you spritzers
oh yeah they're random he did in the
most annoying way wait what do you mean
you were always out i was in like a
little can i was always like uh oh
because i like the seltzers yeah it was
always like a like a light really yeah
imagine seeing your friend who's been
and all of a sudden he's drinking like a
location during a pandemic is kind of
dying weird things are happening i'm
just like is he is i'm like calling all
of our mutual friends like his crows
well i called benji yeah
but anyway so then carlos comes out sees
us and then goes into one of our other
friends cars and coughs all over like
into him like not like i accidentally
coughed like as a joke coughed on his
face
just because he's such a baby i know i'm
glad you did it honestly looking back i
stand by it
he was like trying to go to the
emergency room
he wanted to sue me you you exploded my
whole universe in that moment like my
whole world stopped for weeks you gave
me the strength to block that person
from my life forever wow well we were
all such a squad and then it just like
burned it all to the ground and yeah
like you were threat being threatened
the police legal action
like so good i i was in trouble because
i associate with you oh yeah no we all
got in trouble we all got a screaming
he's big into um if you associate with
someone they don't like they're mad at
you i do not
like that no one [ __ ] me you have a
different relationship with each person
you have it's so selfish like someone
can do bad things to me and i do not
care if someone else hangs out right in
here
oh my god he can't help himself did you
see how he looked at me
wait how did i look at you you were like
oh
wait is that like gay or seductive you
were like into it
you being attracted to me does not make
you less gay i am a very masculine force
[Laughter]
i am uh i i have been the last vagina
for many men
their last hope have you heard that
like the most attractive i heard on
tick-tock
let me guess where'd you get where's
your source what's your source is it
tick-tock maybe
the most attractive people
have like both masculine and feminine
qualities like you have to have like so
i've never like heard that but i i agree
with that because i always accidentally
will swipe right on a trans person
and then
i'll go back and i'll be like wait a
second i think they were trans and i'll
be right and i'm like maybe the
attraction is somewhere in the middle
i think for uh so many people transport
i think is quite a popular well i don't
look at trans porn i'm just saying there
are people in la but is there something
that you like about like a strong show
obviously like strong shoulders
wait why obviously because kalila sits
in that seat with very strong shoulders
my first girlfriend ellie had strong
shoulders wouldn't you like big ted
strong shoulders one of my friends made
fun of me for it at swingers i was like
why are you being mean to hillary so why
was the place we went to called swingers
i love that place swingers is a i just
want to like swing
it's kind of an all-inclusive type of
diner that stayed open long because it
you could get like they had vegan
options they had well also i like
swingers is an iconic la staple it's
like the
especially not now as much but i'm open
to bringing it back but like i feel like
the last like 20 years or whatever it
was just like the coolest iconic l.a
spot is it named after the movie
swingers i don't know like is there some
kind of association i've never
i don't know but you're right like they
have this thing on the menu called the
grown-up grilled cheese and it's like a
healthy grilled cheese with like bean
sprouts that's good and like they have
all these really great menu options and
you go late after shows everyone would
go there you could you'd always be in a
booth next to like drew carey drew
carrick was always next to him oh yeah
totally you have to be careful who
you're talking [ __ ] on because drew
carey is listening
like you you would see celebrities are
the waitresses are so everyone was hot
and cute and it's just like a very
quintessential la experience i had such
a crush on one
tyranny every guy got me out of jail
what when i went to jail for the day
2008.
no i stole something and it was grand
theft he's so rich honestly he's such
that's how rich he is
i went to jail shoplifting you're a
criminal i went to jail two years ago
remember what is your job this is so
humiliating
you do not feel the shame you're
supposed to feel for this i'm about to
make you feel it what did you steal rich
man rich white man i had a nest you're
so lucky or bald you do need something
going against you it was right next to
um swingers actually at this furniture
store called dwr
and i tried to steal something outside
and put it into my suv what was what was
it you were saying it was like a nice
chair or something you remember you it
was like a highlighter went to prison
for it no i only went for like six hours
well you can't see like a lip gloss from
sephora i thought it was going to be i
had an essentially sephora related for
some reason even though he's a guy that
doesn't wear makeup i was like if anyone
shop is from sephora right cape orlando
is like it's a right as a human being to
steal from sephora
today's podcast is brought to you by
nutrafull you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutriful.com trash to save 15 off your
first month subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and is only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get fifteen dollars off at nutrifoal.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
trash and all three of us ladies love
neutral i mean kalila's hair is so thick
that you can't even see her right now
she's hidden in it no i it is
unbelievable how thick my hair is i'm
like freaking out about it neutral
because i knew it was like doing
something but i'm getting to the point i
can't remember how many months i've been
taking it now but maybe four
it's starting to thicken out so much my
hairdresser freaked out and i didn't
notice it she said it and then i've been
like putting my hands to my hair it's
like i might be able to ditch the
extensions and like this is crazy dude i
went to a dinner like a very like hot
girl dinner event and there were girls
there literally talking about neutral
and i was like
i can't believe like we work with them
like i felt so proud but it's the word
of mouth of neutral is getting so off
the chain like
it works it's [ __ ] works it's so
weird you just have to do it for a long
time i just have thicker hair than i've
ever had like it's just
it's just like voluminous and so cool
and my favorite thing about it is it
there's no like scammy element to it
it's not giving you some like weird
product it's all vitamins minerals that
your body actually will use and need
regardless oh you carry yours with you i
put them all in a little when i'm late i
have to run out and in a clinical study
86 of women reported improved hair
growth after six months and more than
fifteen hundred top doctors recommend
neutrophil as an effective and high
quality solution for healthier hair
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription and this is our best offer
anywhere and is only available to you as
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutrifoal.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash trash
they're
just i'm just saying get it and don't
quit like just trust me like look at me
right now i'm not [ __ ] lying to you
i am not lying to you this is
it's crazy what's happening i did not
think this would ever happen to grow
more hair and rather than less like
we're winning at life
it's such a best-case scenario too to
like have this be our sponsor like the
product sells itself realistically it's
just so
good i'm just so excited because i was
like i believed in the product before
but it's like i mean
it's crazy no i know when people notice
annie i understand you use liquid iv oh
i love liquid iv it's so good i wake up
so dehydrated every day i do too and i'm
just i'm really trying to take control
of my hydration they taste so good
they're in these little packets i like
shaking them around you can throw them
anywhere you can put them in your glove
box and your purse it fits in a louie
or another louis well i understand like
i'm sweating a lot more than i usually
do because it's just summer in la and
like i notice i don't feel as good if
i'm not hydrated so this has been an
easy way for me to make sure like i'm
just upping and boosting the hydration
and you just chug it down like i drink
one right when i wake up i feel so good
it's called the um
it's the hydration multiplier okay and
so yeah and it's also it's just making
your water taste good too it tastes
delicious i like the lemon lime the pina
colada is really good
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone and
plus liquid iv products taste great with
10 refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada and tropical
punch oh sounds like summer oh my god
tropical punch
are you sweating you need to come visit
me by the beach i know it's so cool over
there it's good after like i do hot yoga
it's great after hot yoga it's just so
fun you can just take it with you the
packets are so cute you guys can grab
your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com and use code trash tuesday
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code
oh trashtuesdayliquidiv.com legs look
hot is it skim's shirt no we're both
doing the
we both have like short shorts and
leggings esther's covering and i'm just
these were short these are short shorts
on a regular sized person
or checkered
vagina no venus mound you're allowed to
come in here and see where it is
investigate and see how innocent this is
it's tucked under the leg the thought
exactly oh okay but i know how long your
labia is so i know you're touching
vagina
you're sidepipe
stop her someone
i let's go back to swingers so wait
before we go back to swingers can i just
say you didn't know this happened last
time we recorded he just walked into the
bathroom when i was in there like he saw
me go in and then just walked in i
didn't see you carlos has just this
weird entitlement to just like be where
i am
he just walked in like it was so normal
and then you're like you were there for
like a beat before you realized it was
wrong
well both of us were i i understand
you know what i had to do i would like
to take a [ __ ]
should we file a formal report with
bryce against yeah yes carlos is out
[Laughter]
um we just find another guy with
carlos's balding pattern
it's that guy for it's um the guy what's
the
um stephen wright
it's the convenience store says i just
flew in and my arms are so tired
i can't we know like the origin of that
yeah do the black and the black yeah
that was his the black and white there
we go he's the only one that can see
that's a look like nobody told him to
shave right what else has it um well he
did kind of his character
what's his name
the greek comedian yeah but oh he does
grow it out a little but he's kind of
like really bald on top
i did a podcast with them once he's so
funny and so steven wright
is he alive
he looks like in the hat up there no i
was about to say he's kind of hot but
i'm like if he's still alive i don't
want to put that does everyone just
morph into looking like jeff ross like
every comedian just like grows into jeff
frost with different hair why do i feel
like i look like jeff ross too you will
oh by the way
i realized
what my mission is now i want everyone
if they want to get plastic surgery and
if they want to get like worked under
their face i want them to do it okay but
now that i've really started exploring
contouring and stuffing and patting my
bra
i really like the idea of giving
yourself like a temporary boob job a
temporary nose job temporary like
everything temporary tattoo is that
temporary
they're really not kala will be not
talking to you by the time that wears
off like she will never be taking your
calls again and that's f you you don't
think i'm ready and willing for that
i've been i don't want to be rude i have
been manifesting it
i i don't i just the idea of you her
hating you i never want to speak to you
and you having to look at her name every
day is so delicious it will never bother
me wait what is so temporary like i want
to start doing like how to give yourself
a boob job how to give yourself because
then you get to just have your regular
body on the other days
like i will ever since the pamela
anderson episode ever since we did the
baywatch episode i just every three days
will just give myself like the biggest
fakest hits okay the thing that's weird
with you is that you
look very good and you haven't had any
work done and it's and and it's not even
like you live like an easy lifestyle
it's like you're like
a maniac
was that like what was that an [ __ ] i
was eating
sexual you're just like out there living
life talking and like you but you look
very good i don't know what i think i'm
ha i think it's i'm glowing from the
inside i'm happy
and contour
i i'm telling you like what you use tic
tac for is very different but i do feel
like you you're
you're a woman that has like masculine
touches and you're a man with feminine
touches what are my feminine touches
um your slenderness slender man
my dieting
your dieting is very feminine i'm
nervous that i'll lose my butt though
from dieting
what
what do you think annie do you guys are
you planning on losing more weight no
i'm just afraid that it'll go away wait
should carlos get a bbl a brazilian butt
lift he can i don't need it i can start
looking into this on tick tock and i can
find a way to give him a temporary oh
yeah that's right i just like the i
don't like how permanent no work is that
people are getting and it's also
expensive and not safe like people
get hurt
or like people like similar to kalila
like i have a girlfriend who got breast
implants and she said like it just made
her whole body inflamed for like a year
it's scary yeah i like they are cute
though they do look great
really yeah you're a power bottom
i swear that's what i heard that is not
what you heard
i said i'm whatever about them
wow
i did not hear that
you hear what you want to hear
um
but yeah by the way last night i
never comment on what an audience is
like i never care it's never a thing but
last night
like
there was a girl who was very i'm just
gonna assume drunk very excited to be
there
and it's it was such a weird experience
annie like have you had this where
they the they're your fan
but they're
disrupting the whole show yes every
you don't remember that story
i stuffed the [ __ ] you you [ __ ] with
them here's the thing these shows sound
fun they sound like a whole they are so
they are actually so fantastic they are
they're almost interactive don't
actually have questions we should buy
tickets me and you
full price vip
yeah there's no vip charge unless it's
youtube
um
it's gonna like
i'm so used to the experience of like
people respecting you no way worse than
that like when silently watching and
wondering when there's a heckler
it's like someone who like doesn't know
who you are and they [ __ ] hate you
and then you hate them and it's like
this hateful war but if it's someone
who's like actually
like is your fan you're
i never get mad because it's like i'm
always like it's so i always say i go
it's so annoying because like you're
being so nice like thank you i know but
shut the [ __ ] up like i just have 80d so
it's like you guys are gonna i can't
this is gonna be hard but sometimes i've
just made the show all about one person
which i hope the rest of the audience
likes i
i will say i'm becoming more and more
into that version of things because i do
realize like
people do like the live experience and
like i think things that go wrong or
like if i was in the audience i would
like that my favorite esther mad on
stage moment because it's very rare oh
god there's your mother
no
it's so they're always bad what i'm
saying no this was great at the comedy
store there's a waitress who's been
working there since
probably 1920. like honestly it's like
she built the place like let's just say
she knew mitzi and personally like she's
just been there so long she just happens
to be like you know when deaf people
scream like like so unaware a lot like
the loudest person you've ever met and
she's a waitress so she's in a comedy
club she was being so loud esther goes
i'm sorry can you shut the [ __ ] up
to the waitress and it was so good
because she's always like the loudest
you're like i can't even think it was
good i don't feel like i'm pulling off
the story that well but it was amazing i
i do remember that and then i found out
i was waitress and i was horrified oh
really yeah no she should know better
than anyone else no it was very loud it
was and it's like
things now i'm a little more chill
things go wrong you just kind of let it
go but there is
a [ __ ]
there was like a period of time though
where it's like
and you i know that you know what i'm
talking about like you waited all day
for the stage time that that was like
all you put in it was it's so valuable
and important to you and then like
things throw it off and you're just like
but now i know that's just what happened
yeah that's life but like there was a
point in time where that would really
upset me no especially when you think
because i think you were prepping for
your special then yes i was yeah when
you're like you have like a mission and
it's just it's it's honestly our fault
if we go in thinking that we're gonna
be able to have like full control you're
right it is our job to like contr
maintain some control over the audience
but there's only so much you can you
know you're totally right it's up it's
our it's my responsibility
rogan reviews tick tocks crazy terms of
service yesterday it's actually insane
and one thing i'm i'm gonna predict one
thing i know is that like if you show a
vape in your tick tock video they take
it down is it oh really yeah like you
can but i guess this is more what we're
agreeing to give away or something oh
okay okay let's see
is it good or bad bad it's so what are
you saying it's a bad place to be listen
to this
this is uh from tick tock's privacy
policy all right it said uh we collect
certain information about the device you
use to access the platform
such as your ip address um
user region
this is this is really crazy
uh user agent mobile carrier time zone
settings i identifiers for advertising
purpose model of your device the device
system network type device ids your
screen resolution and operating system
app and file names and types so all your
apps and all your file names all the
things you have filed away on your phone
they have access to that file names and
types key stroke patterns or rhythms so
they're monitoring your keystrokes which
means they know every [ __ ] thing you
type wow battery state
uh audio settings and connected audio
devices where you login
multiple devices you'll be able to use
your profile information to identify
your activity across devices we may also
associate you with information collected
from devices other than those you know
you use to log into the platform meaning
they can use other computers that you're
not even using to log into tick tock
they can suck the data off that that's
what you're agreeing to
when you download and start using
tiktok wild it's insane my question
would be do you
well okay i feel like theo is about to
go my question is what is an ip address
and i would love to hear that answer
because i also don't know well what i'll
say is like i feel like i've i try to be
one of those people that's like resigned
to like they have it all
that's like obsessive though for the
first time for me we're not going to get
estraf tic-tac no well no of course not
but but esther have you ever said the
term tick-tock is life
no has anyone felt it yeah
how'd you know
do you are you working at tick-tock and
you know my thoughts
you're chinese no but like i just i feel
like there's those people that become
obsessed with i have to be hiding and
my freedom and my privacy and by the way
i respect that like i want my freedom
and privacy too but i've also just given
up it's like no one what
it's like
how much more time do i have on the
earth anyway you know the only real
privacy you have i've never lived to a
hundred it's not that many years
you're gonna you think you're gonna live
to 100. i said even if i did i will live
very old though you know what i never
get scared of like i think so too for me
this is what i do that my protection
i've decided because
i've worked a lot through my ptsd just
from crazy [ __ ] that's happened to me or
whatever so when i'm in like a ptsd
flare-up which happened to me in one of
my relationships where i was just like
so
i kept feeling thinking i was gonna get
robbed i had like a stalker in my
building it was like so scary
and i just kept i was so like
weapons everywhere
i've just had so many weird times where
i've had to like
be armed it's just like scary like my
whole life almost not that i'm saying
like i still have a gun i have like
weapons and stuff
but i just was in this like i felt so
like
you've i felt the thinness of the walls
do you know what i mean like i felt like
i could get robbed at any time like i
was just like feeling like really kind
of exposed and i couldn't
there's nothing i can do to not once
you're in the place where you're
noticing that you're kind of like
vulnerable it's really like
nothing you can do we just all are
vulnerable in life we have no control
over the outside world when they have
control of ourselves so i decided that i
have to do it rather than thinking of it
physically i have to think about it more
like emotionally and like vibration
level
so i just always imagine myself having
this wonderful amazing life as just an a
super fun crazy old lady i love this and
then i never i don't get scared like
when i'm in fear i just think that i'm
like no [ __ ] you're not taking my
like you already know the past yeah
you're just stepping in like the movie's
already written and i'm just like living
in it now no i i really i
i feel like you almost got
like i took lexapro so that i could have
that
like i am there i'm like there now but i
i never would have gotten there without
anti-anxiety medication my cousin is a
swat team in southern he's a swat team
member in southern california he's the
whole team yeah he is
can you believe they tried to swat him
out of the womb and he still lived
remember that
um yeah and he kind of
he kind of like made me feel better and
worse at the same time he's like there
is not much you can do it's like you
know you have whatever weapons you want
to have to protect you but like
if people want
whatever why i don't want to talk about
this no but it's like if you're tense
and scared you're like living in that
like do you notice how every
and this is not victim shaming obviously
these are all horrible things but when i
used to watch true crime i would always
notice they always would be like she
loved dateline
do you know what i mean
it's like
that's a theory i feel like you have
that i don't know if i agree with
because i've ne i listen to so much of
that i used to
and
i know we both were on some sick little
kicks
i
why during the pandemic was that the
thing we were doing for me it was before
the pandemic i think
was it although one time oh my god so i
one time i showed dave like a 2020 about
like this like big
story that was really scary and he
cannot handle that [ __ ] he was like i
feel like he was gonna break up with me
he was like i can't believe you have
that thought a lot
it was just from 2020
yeah no 2020 no they're dark no i know
but like
it's tvpg
it is weird that that is considered tv
pg just like hardcore murders they show
like blood on things and stuff like why
is that like allowed to be on tv i
watched the one where all those girls
were trapped in that house out by like
palm springs oh my god and like one of
the girls was like kind of pretty a
birthday party i went to once
[Laughter]
wait i know i'm like that sounds fun no
that's just like finally a sleepover
it's a lock-in
faster
what
just imagining you
just like in a lock-in and just
things go wrong and then it's just you
it's bad you're the murderer
in that pete davidson movie you're the
killer
who who here is the most likely to have
people trapped in their basement i know
it's me yeah it's obviously you okay
harlow's who is home wearing that
haircut
he's hiding something he's distracting
i'm so chill i wouldn't murder anyone i
would shoot no we didn't say murdered
we'd say that trapped down there wait
what was the nasa story that you pulled
up
nasa's scientist explains why astronauts
should not masturbate in zero gravity
weight why
does it go back inside yeah the sperm
like finds its way apparently
it's like very
so pre-squirting i could masturbate
yeah
wait what happens well in zero gravity
the sperm like just like floats around
and it's a hazard it's like a health
hazard did you read this are you
guessing i've read it well you're not
telling us what it is i know you're just
it's right there too well i'm not
reading i can't read and also that's far
away i'll i'll read it everyone
i forgot we have people saved your ass
no and also pizza in the carlo's chair
doing a better job than carlos has ever
done
a chair pete thank you you're welcome
okay so astronauts
is that your final answer is the only
one who respects us so you can get uh
impregnated by straight fluids it's
basically that was gonna be my guess and
that's not what he said i know that's
not what you said i say you said it's
gonna help around no i was gonna say
that would just get sucked into our
wombs it would just be floating and
going if i said oh yeah sperm floats
around and can get into your vagina
you'd be like did you read it dear
audience what you are seeing today is a
dramatized performance yes everyone here
takes their children seriously it's a
re-enactment
these are not real people these are
actors
maybe a banana break
[Music]
i'm about to walk off this show oh my
god if carlos walks i will be so happy
carlos you stay put okay no i'm about to
walk off this is so sweet because he
needs because
he's such a rich kid isn't he being such
a rich kid why so i don't need a [ __ ]
banana from heroin you weren't going to
eat it
oh would you want to try to get in your
mouth no no no no why did you open your
mouth i thought you were going to throw
it at my mouth i think you wanted a kiss
you all are so dumb
don't
do you want to go take like five do you
want to take a walk yeah i'm going to
take five okay take a car let's watch
you want your banana
are you gonna eat it
do you eat bananas
he's not being serious
i don't know what's going on all we
wanted was you to read us the story
i think it's you and me together is he
leaving
they're back to them
your bag's unzipped
are you worried about like are you mad
at him are you worried
i'm like somewhere in the middle i'm
like i can't tell i'm like
i want to be like what are you okay
this is like some andy kaufman [ __ ] like
i don't know i think wait is this a
[ __ ]
that's the thing because he's always
like get the smile and he doesn't know
when he's yelling he's like i'm not
yelling at you and you're like
you are but um
how did you get into the comedy store
when you first like did you when you
showed up to la did you come to be an
actress or a comedian no i knew i wanted
to do stand-up and
i was at a it was literally the day i
got here
and
i went out to a bar and i was like
goofing off with my friend that i was
gonna stay with and like being i was
being like really goofy because i was
like so happy and excited yeah you're
like manic for cutting yeah just got to
this town and the woman who owned the
bar was like you're really funny you
should do stand-up comedy and i was like
i literally just moved here to do that
but i have no idea how or what or where
did she card you at any point was she
like who let this child i don't remember
she did but i was i was exactly 21 and
she was
yeah and she was like oh well i just
know about the comedy store
she's like that's where i go to watch
shows and then i just like the next day
called
and was like how do i and i like brought
in a resume and they never hired me but
oh you were gonna be a door girl no
there was no such thing as a door girl
then it was like girls could only be a
waitress and you can't want to do comedy
if you're a waitress right yeah i think
they were not into that as much and yeah
they wouldn't hire me that's so funny
how recently it was just like totally
sexist
like not that long ago i know like i
always think about that like when you
and i started in stand-up it was very
not the way it is now and i just don't
even like i choose to not ever
acknowledge the sexism because it's too
annoying yeah i try and it's not funny
to be like no sexist
yeah but it's like oh yeah things were
bad and also the way like the met creepy
men in the comedy store treated thought
it was okay to treat women literally
there was a there are groups of men
actively like hating the women that came
there and didn't want them to be there
and would like bully them so they'd
leave know and it works i was like but
the thing is that happened right before
i came i know what crew you're talking
about i think yeah
and i did see one guy there was one guy
that used to like
really like to piss women off in the
audience and i remember one time he said
something to this girl and she threw a
glass
shattered this glass down at him did you
ever have an outburst at the comedy
store because i once threw a drink in a
guy's face there
i had the guy i think i told you about
the guy you were on stage and throw a
drink at him yeah
i came off stage and i
i forgot what he said but it was really
so like way too rude and i didn't know
him
it was like when we were doing the late
night shows and it was like all com
comedy people in the room so like i knew
everybody but then some guy i didn't
know said something really degrading to
me and i was you know [ __ ] 21 i just
walked off stage grabbed at someone
else's half drunk drink and threw it in
his face that's so did you have to pay
for the person's drink no but then i
ended up dating that guy a year later
that you threw the drink in yeah
it's very weird
is it weird or not obvious maybe this is
carlos's big move on you
like in a year she's going to love me
did you see nope no did you it was so
good really he loved it did you guys see
it no i haven't seen it because i'm
cause some people don't like it and
here's what i decided when i was
watching the movie i'm not going to
worry about plot holes i'm not going to
worry about if things don't really make
sense yeah i'm just going to be like am
i enjoying every scene and every [ __ ]
scene was good that's how i like to
watch movies too yeah i i his last movie
us was one of my favorite movies i've
ever seen in my life like it's so good i
loved it because i didn't see us and
then i was like getting worried i was
like what if he's like an m night
shyamalan where even though eminem's
movies are awesome it's just like he had
that one really good one but this is a
certified genius i mean it is so [ __ ]
i also think eminent milan is like he's
still so good yeah he's still so good
but it's just like none of them had as
good of a hit as like
um
the sixth sense the sixth sense the
signs i really like so you're just
naming two already that you are amazing
so no i know i'm asking for too much but
you know
science was like somehow i look back on
that and that's the most terrified i've
ever been in a theater and is it because
you're jewish and um mel gibson wasn't
it
and he denies your heritage
[Laughter]
someone that's given i felt terrified
too but it says someone has given blow
jobs in a hot tub before i knew he's
gonna scream at me do you remember that
what's crazy is i like are you i think
you might be right
it was like did he get busted for the
anti-semitic stuff like a couple years
after science i feel like it was i don't
know must have been because i think the
only thing he did after that was like
joke movies where they were using him as
like the charlie sheen but i do want to
say that i agree with you very
like hugely on am i enjoying the movie
or not because
i feel like i know people dave it's like
he's
he is focused like is the story right is
it good and all that which is that's its
own thing but i'm like i just want to
have fun while i'm watching it journey
not the destination yes and because
we've all been on sets of movies and
stuff before and dave is a writer so
it's like hard for him to not look at it
as like a writer right but
when a movie is like if i i'm not
thinking about that then that's how good
the movie is yes there were just so many
like scenes like i just think of it like
the storyboard of it and i'm like it's
like if you're sucked into a world like
that's you got your money's it's just so
it's just was so fun but todd was like i
don't like the i'm like todd we're being
nonsense here this was good we went and
saw it it was the first time i've done
d-box what's that it's like the seats
that vibrate like with the movie whoa
and there's all this horseback riding
and stuff so you're like
they're like clumping around itself
wait that's crazy did you see elvis i
haven't seen it was it good it's so good
but it's a musical right
i don't think it they don't like break
into song in the middle of conversation
there's just some
little musicals like you see him
performing okay
no no it's not i feel betrayed like when
i went to dream girls and they just
started like they're just like hanging
out in like the office
[Music]
carlos could have been a part of that
his dream
this was his dream carlos blew his whole
dream
he starts doing open mics again i'm like
so nervous as to what i'm like well i
want to get to the bottom of why you're
nervous
because i just feel responsible for him
like i feel like because you're the one
that introduced him to everyone maybe
yeah i'm like i'm like is he okay is he
what's he going through
are you worried about his emotional
things or how what he's doing is gonna
fall on you
it's okay to i don't know
i really don't know are you like worried
you're gonna get like
fat
like you're not gonna have someone to
help you with your calories anywhere
or you're like oh no i had a good thing
going he blew it
you are he's great
well it works i think this is and i
think this is how he feels that it's
nothing
yeah
you're right it's actually my
codependence like
most like i feel like a healthy person
would be like all right
move on he like slammed the door to make
a point like he's doing a bit i really
do believe that
he should be punished for the bit
oh yeah when kalyan comes back she
should administer the punishment no i
think a boss should administer i think
he should actually get into trouble but
we can also whip him on camera
but he would like that
i don't know what he will like and
dislike he is a weird guy he's a weird
guy he switches
like does anyone know the real carlos
all right let's let's start by uh
let's watch this video someone just got
sued for uh ten thousand for standing
somebody up on a first date
[Music]
oh my god i'd be rich
people you know would be owe me money
a court case near detroit sounds like a
romantic comedy gone wrong a woman sues
a man for thousands of dollars after he
stood her up on a date fox's jessica
duke knack has the details
i feel for the defendant
i mean you know like i said
he should have swiped left
too late now for richard jordan who's
being sued for 10 thousand dollars after
he allegedly didn't show up for a date
with kashante short back in 2020 in
flint she says he caused emotional
distress because the date fell on her
late mom's birthday
mr jordan let me just ask you this are
you planning to
uh represent yourself on this
uh
i i i
to be honest with you sir i i thought
this was just gonna be thrown out
todd you've been doing this a minute i
love this guy look at his outfit
um if i've seen something like this i've
seen someone go to jail defense attorney
todd perkins wasn't in on this hearing
but says the judge has the patience of a
saint as ms short tried schooling him on
everything during this recent zoom
hearing do not assault my intelligence
as if i do not understand what the word
perjury means be quiet while i'm talking
you need to be quiet
like several other of miss short's
bizarre lawsuits this one too got booted
from district oh my god she's esther
alleged bad date guy lawsuit girl to him
you know
he's going to get some good dates off of
his
i have thoughts which is like why
say you're going to show up if you're
not going to [ __ ] show up you deserve
to be on our side why
say you're going to go on the date this
should be happening to set an example
just say you're not going say no don't
make the plan why make the plan no it's
annoying to be stood up but also why did
you make a date on your late mom's
birthday
if you're in such distress you needed
that dick so bad also you're in flint
michigan you guys have bigger dish
issues
you got to get your water
i think they have that face does they
have a victim i really hope so
i love that you took the
do you not take her like are you suing
him
but haven't you ever been stood up and
been like why is this allowed yeah and
then you know what i feel like oh like
oh that hurt my feelings and then i like
get over it
it's not about that that's one choice 10
that if you i'm sorry if someone doesn't
show up on a date
and it causes you ten thousand dollars
worth of distress like you have work on
yourself you must do okay i think the
number is hard that's definitely a heart
attack what do you think what do you
think she should have stood for a
thousand i think it's like it yeah i
think it's like enough to
so that i would have enough money to
like have an awesome night to replace
the trauma of that night a thousand
would be great i could like do some
online shopping get high in edibles
order a lot of postmates like
a thousand dollars would be enough
but wait can we do a thousand dollar
challenge when we ever do a live show
listen well it's got to be money we've
made off of an extra event with trash
tuesday okay okay we take each other on
a thousand a thousand dollar night each
or maybe we can do we just spend a
thousand dollars between us
yeah like what could we do with a
thousand bucks well i think the most
obvious first thought that we should do
is like go
yes oh yeah duh but like go to one of
those really fancy fancy sushi like
omakase things that i'm always too
scared and too cheap to do
that things are afraid of her
wow i love that one i think she's
setting a precedent that we should fight
back if people want to stand us up the
guy being like i thought this would be
thrown out was so
he was so it was like i'm so sorry like
is this a prank like he's literally like
waiting for like a clown to run in that
the delivery of that line his feet i
felt that man
and i associated with him more not that
i don't think i've ever stood anyone up
if i stood someone up and said oh when i
was babysitting once this is [ __ ] up
actually i was a babysitter i was like
14. i stood this family i've
accidentally just completely flaked on
it just add style forgot
i had to babysit for them and i felt so
bad i was like i will babysit for you
for free because they had some plans
that they couldn't go on i felt so bad
it was like they were yelling at my mom
i was like oh my god i'm so sorry
i was like i will make this up to you
like i will babysit for you for free
i [ __ ] up and i missed that one too
and that was like a subconscious thing
like that was like
isn't that crazy
i was at the movies and my mom like i we
didn't have cell phones or anything yet
so i'm trying i'm so scared and paged by
my mom and i can't she was you [ __ ]
forgot again i was like oh my god and
it's more it works for my mom i'm just a
kid they're looking at my mom like you
dumb [ __ ] like you offered your kid to
be our babysitter it was like a neighbor
we just saw in the neighborhood we just
see him at the park
and then i did i don't know if i it was
it must have been after i babysat for
them because i remember i did actually
babysit for the kid once
and i was trying to be like the cool
baby sorry i gave him like skit like he
wasn't supposed to have skittles until
he like finished his meal
and i was like you guys have skittles
your parents aren't here and he was like
i don't like that he like didn't want to
like i was like okay good job kid i he's
like you trashy [ __ ] no honestly it was
like maybe that's why i [ __ ]
subconsciously i don't hang out with
this nerd
i'm trying to hang out with a kid
that'll eat nerds come on i thought i
was like being the cool
like it was it was just skittles it's
not like i was like let's smoke weed
little kid
i was like you can have the skittles you
don't have to finish your dinner
he was like that's not the rules oh my
god and then i subconsciously blocked
ever going back there again that's a
thing it's because it's like if you do
it twice it's there's something going on
right it's like you your brain doesn't
want secretly doesn't want you to go
yeah something deep within yeah a
psychological thing i wanted to say
regardless both people in that court
case are major stars and like they need
to be on they need more camera time and
i don't know if that was the goal
because she did look cute
yeah
he was just like he was they he was in
the shadows he was like look those two
on a reality show trying to make a
relationship work it's like you and
carlos after this week
[Laughter]
will we ever see carlos again guys
comment in the down in the comments i
don't know what happened i'm like
hopefully this is a planted bit that i'm
not aware of i can't wait to see the
tapes back because he is wrong
and we're gonna see the point where he
realized he was wrong and there was no
point of return where he had to lash out
i'm very excited he's kind of like
giving emotional abuse vibes it's so
funny we watch back and we're like
horrible to him
yeah but you know the truth is we are
you know in front of the camera so we do
still win carlos i'm sorry oh god um you
guys we'll be back next week with a
brand new episode of this show some way
somehow we need you to send a video in
of why you should replace carlos and
what you will do for our show that will
make it so much better than miss carlito
we love you guys we love you so much
thank you for going through this
emotional rollercoaster i don't know who
will be here next week and who will not
be i promise you it won't be me i'm out
i've had my last banana
[Music]
you